♪.
PETE: ARIZONA DEPLOYING THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO HELP COMBAT
THE STATE'S SPIRALS CRISIS AT
ITS SOUTHERN BORDER.
WILL: THE MAYOR OF YUMA ALSO
DECLARING A LOCAL EMERGENCY AS
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS FLOODED
THE CITY WITHIN THE LAST FIVE
DAYS.
RACHEL: HE JOINS US WITH THE
LATEST ON THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND, THE MAYOR OF YUMA,
DOUGLAS NICHOLLS.
MAYOR, SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON
THE SHOW.
FIRST OF ALL, MERRY CHRISTMAS,
WELCOME.
I HAVE MANY FRIENDS IN YUMA THEY
HAVE BEEN TELLING ME A LONG TIME
THINGS WERE GOING VERY BADLY.
SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A NEW LOW IN
THE CRISIS.
TELL ME WHAT'S HAPPENING AND HOW
YOUR COMMUNITY IS DEALING WITH
IT.
>> WELL, WE'RE CURRENTLY IN SOME
UNPRECEDENTED WATERS HERE.
UP TO THIS POINT THIS LAST YEAR
WE HAD A VERY CONTAINED
SITUATION.
BORDER PATROL AND I.C.E. WERE
ABLE TO WORK WITH SOME
NON-PROFITS TO BRING PEOPLE
THROUGH THE SYSTEM WITHOUT A
WHOLE LOT OF IMPACT TO THE
COMMUNITY.
WELL LAST WEEKEND WE HAD 6,000
PEOPLE CAME OVER THE, FOUR-DAY
PERIOD WHICH OVERWHELMED THE
BORDER PATROL SYSTEM.
SO PEOPLE WERE WAITING AT THE
BORDER FOR BORDER PATROL TO PICK
THEM UP FOR ALMOST A DAY, A
DAY 1/2.
THEY STARTED WALKING THROUGH
TOWN AND, DOING WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO, TAKE CARE OF HUMANITARIAN
ISSUES, WATER, FOOD, AND SHELTER
ON THEIR WAY TO TRYING TO FIND A
BORDER PATROL STATION.
THAT CAUSED THE COMMUNITY A
LITTLE BIT OF CHAOS.
BUT REALLY WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THE DECLARATION IS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT THE EPICENTER AFTER
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS THAT CAN BE
QUICKLY DEVELOPING.
PETE: MR. MAYOR, BASED ON YOUR
CALCULATION, WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING, WHY NOW, WHY THIS
MANY?
>> IT IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
MYSTERY.
I THINK THIS IS A
REIMPLEMENTATION OF THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY.
THAT IS A UNDERSTANDING.
THAT POLICY HAS BEEN
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED WHEN IT IS
FULLY IMPLEMENTED, IT WILL ONLY
PROVIDE ROOM FOR 10 PEOPLE A DAY
OUT OF YUMA SECTOR.
IT WILL NOT DRAMATICALLY CHANGE
WHAT WE'VE GO GOING ON HERE,
THAT IS 1% OF THE TRAFFIC COMING
THROUGH.
BUT I THINK THAT PANIC TRYING TO
GET IN THE COUNTRY BEFORE, THAT
PROGRAM WAS BACK INTO EFFECT.
WILL: MAYOR YOU DECLARED A LOCAL
EMERGENCY, YOU SAID TO GET AHEAD
OF WHAT COULD BE A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS A BURGEONING HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE IN YOUR
TOWN?
>> RIGHT NOW WE'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE, SINCE I DECLARED THE
NUMBERS HAVE DROPPED.
IT IS MORE AMONGABLE FOR BORDER
PATROL.
SHOULD THEY STAYED AT THAT
LEVEL, HUNDREDS, POTENTIALLY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AT A TIME
LOOKING FOR WATER, LOOKING FOR
FOOD, WALKING THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY, BUT NOT JUST THE CITY
ITSELF BUT THE SURROUNDING
AGRICULTURAL AREAS.
SO THAT'S, VERY IMPORTANT FOR TO
US MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THINGS
DON'T HAPPEN BECAUSE OF THE
ANCILLARY IMPACTS, IMPACTS TO
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
IMPACTS TO JUST, THE GENERAL
HUMANITARIAN ISSUES THAT ARISE.
YOU HAVE THAT MANY PEOPLE
WITHOUT RESOURCES.
WILL: WHERE WILL THEY USE THE
RESTROOM?
SANITARY ISSUES?
I CAN'T IMAGINE ALL OF SUDDEN
INFLUX OF THOUSANDS HOW YOU DEAL
WITH THAT?
THAT'S ONE PROBLEM AND THAT'S A
BIG ONE.
>> YES.
THIS TIME OF YEAR, WHILE WE'RE
IN THE DESERT IT DROPS.
RACHEL MIGHT REMEMBER THIS, IT
DROPS REALLY COLD IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT.
DURING THE DAY IT IS SUNNY AND
GRAY.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT IT IS
FREEZING.
WE'RE TALKING LITTLE KIDS,
TALKING ELDERLY PEOPLE.
TALKING PEOPLE AT RISK.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN
EITHER.
RACHEL: YOUR CALL FOR HELP
HOPEFULLY WILL BE HEARD.
TWO DEMOCRATIC SENATORS WANT
SOMETHING TO BE DONE ABOUT IT.
MAYBE SOMETHING WILL BE DONE,
MAYBE NOT.